hello and welcome to this video playing
Adam conch of turkey serrated to 144
someone suggested I should read out the
ratings because they have trouble seeing
it on small displays so why not can
promise that it do it every time I tend
to forget those things okay yeah it's
high time for scoring it really is being
being close to below 2300 is some rings
alarm bells so what to do here g4 is
very aggressive but rather typical kind
of maneuver here hmm and so it's very
dangerous actually okay I try to go for
some central account to play I can still
go g5 if he likes yeah okay
so what to do yeah I probably have to
correct that night take see five its
third some d5 here i think that should
i'm a bit skeptical about 95
can also go be 5v5 Bishop b3 take stakes
and then d5 I rellahan scared with the
GF I'll kill heck I'm completely honest
with you that is dangerous but you grab
this pawn well as I said I'm a bit
skeptical about this because now i'm
getting play in the center whoa really
interesting so kia soul
how to do that him I would like to go
rookie aid but i am going to see scott
some issues here to coordinate maybe
just seasick so i can play hookie aid b5
is doing the same thing with the temper
but i also rely txt five i want to
prevent it's not so easy for him still
to coordinate this position he cannot
prepare long castles the night on
divorce is really annoying
yeah a sensible probably so rook e8
yeah it's not easy for white not easy so
it's not obvious what I should do okay
I'm not getting checkmated anymore on
the G file that's not happening ok I'm
happy about that so what now I think I
have various ways to just being okay I'm
just thinking I'm if I example I can
just take everything here and and
equalize take g4 be 3c three and and be
okay but it's a little bit yeah doesn't
doesn't feel like the best
okay I'm going with this I'm not sure I
want to go Quinn to g5 possibly f5 on a
very good day at five but ok value f5 is
not so bad if i get an f5 and he has to
take with the e pawn I would be very
happy with that because then his bishop
won't be three and the knight on c3 are
permanently out of game for continuing
with the most aggressive possible
continuation okay i think i'll shoot for
this f5 if he takes at five now I'm
having a pretty nice position okay
probably he had to but still so I'm not
sure what the both both look good both
recaptures
93 is a nice threat
okay so i can go nite g3 now I take on
g4 if I like or just this one they're
just going back it's not bad you cannot
play rookie one here it's hard for him
to challenge the night now t5 I could
probably take age three what is my next
move probably queen to d6 and tendon
Queen g6 and try to ok I don't
understand that why can I not just take
here now okay I don't see it
yeah he blundered but it was it was
difficult to play I think tonight aged
60 move let's come on that just take
this prevent this stuff
white resins term them immensely
complicated okay let's see how this
unfolded yeah this is a sideline there
should be six and designed to keep a
little bit more play in the position and
some other lines here and there four
nights it gets so boring so I this is
designed to do you have to be a little
bit more active yeah I wonder if castles
now g4 is very interesting and dangerous
okay I think this this looks okay I
believe getting some counter play in the
center now this yeah Bishop takes hmm
yeah that pin is a real issue this is
why I went back and I thought that
taking on your five is very risky I
think it's um I was thinking more look G
1 norm move like that that keeps that
aggressive intentions going so well this
is this is dangerous I don't don't like
my position here probably castles was
some was too early no no that doesn't
look good after this I mean at least
from a practical point of view I think I
like my position here a lot more because
I can i can get active and and this I
don't know yeah the engine basically
gives me a clear advantage after that
yeah I had the feeling in the game as
well rook g1 and probably and hear the
engine still likes white it might be
possible maybe he can rap e5 and still
he still has those ideas I mean even
after grabbing the porn
it's probably still better for wide and
just get engine gives white slide edge
0.4 yeah yeah I'm clearly better already
Bishop h4 is given instead of c6
interesting what happens on this f5 and
flag wins Wow yeah okay I hear ya the
computers was totally merciless yeah of
it wins it wins this looks immensely
brutal check and then King age 7 yeah
this is the den group g1 is still kind
of funky it I can go here and the
computer just says minus 2.5 oh my god
yeah okay but I think this is a human
humanly I think good move right yeah
seems to give like a slight advantage at
least for you and hear that he had
sickly advantage both both recaptures
did look fine yet here he blundered with
94 it's not easy to play in the problem
assembly as his long-term issue here
with the king it just doesn't look very
safe and this is not participating the
computer wants to play King g2
working-age one after which I probably
play and or something like this with
this idea and just Bishop d7 I'm just I
just play I mean I don't really have to
rush things here the important thing is
that he cannot challenge on the eve hard
because of that Bishop here and I have
clear idea see a queen g6 bishop
researchers pile up and he cannot do
much those two pieces out of play
so think like it's in really good shape
okay thanks for watching